we set out to make a better basketball
shoe and I think we did but the truth is
we didn't set out to have this legacy we
didn't set out to have this conversation
in 1989 I helped bring the Reebok pump
to life not only was a game evolving
knowing where the athletes getting
bigger and stronger and performing at a
much higher level we were in a
competition with our competitors to
become the preeminent supplier of
basketball shoes players were looking
for whatever edge they could attain much
like they do today what they always
wanted was better fit and better support
we've already had really great
basketball product so we weren't sure
what to do we ended up looking outside
of the athletic for industry and we
looked at what they were using in skiing
we looked at what they used for air
splints we looked at how they created a
snug fit we ended up settling on this
really new and novel concept where we
use an air bladder to customize the fit
and support in Reebok shoes to make the
bladder work it ended up bringing this
one component to the price of what a
normal shoe was we weren't sure if the
consumer would embrace $170 shoe when it
was nearly double the cost of most other
shoes at that time switch to the
greatest sports for furniture in the
world the Reebok pump
so what happened was coming out of the
gate there was a fairly lackluster order
but where it really took off was on a
short while later there was a rookie
basketball player for the Boston Celtics
his name was Dee Brown dee had been
invited to the slam dunk competition he
was not expected to be a contender to
win the slam dunk competition when he
went to do his dunks before every dunk
he bent over and pumped up his shoes and
in that moment Dee Brown changed the
pump to being something that was in a
whole different realm it's just it was a
different kind of product and it became
kind of legendary right there
he did an old local slam dunk that kind
of wild the crowd and it worked out real
well for D and that that definitely
changed the game we knew early on that
we had something different but we didn't
set out with this notion of of being
able to be talking about it 25 years
later